wen en plein centre de offrons de
dire pin les tanks russes ont juste là
j'ai pu parcourir
quelques les quelques kilomètres avec
tes des combattants qui m'ont permis de
rentrer donc ici il ya toute une
population de résistants et il ya encore
des familles et qui sont dans des
bunkers c'est réellement un
foutu de la ville qui est en résistance
sommes ici réellement en frau
la mayo kani
voilà
ces fumées noires sont
les attaques d'artillerie de temps que
c'est ça
tracteur qui a été reconvertie en
donc pour avancer avec des civils voilà
où on est ça c'est exactement la ligne
de front c'est l'avenue principale de
dire pin dans laquelle nous avons pu
progresser avec ses combattants il y a
encore il ya encore beaucoup de civils
qui continuent d'évacuer et il y à des
tireurs d'élite russes qui sont à 500
mètres de là où je me trouve donc une
zone assez compliqué ici dans le coeur
de dire pid donc voici exactement
voici exactement où avance
les forces russes et où est bien à des
combattants et des résistants d'hier pin
sur ce front du nord ouest sont prêts à
en découdre 7 comme vous pouvez le voir
cette ville est maintenant attaquer en
permanence et nous sommes du côté qui
est toujours maintenue par les forces du
crânienne mais les tanks russes sont à
quelques centaines de mètres de là où je
me trouve et donc la situation
évidemment est assez tordu et droit
devant moi ce sont mes artères de la
ville et puis ces fameux km qui mène à
kiev ou sur continuent de se réfugier
énormément de résidents qui sont encore
bloquées de ce côté de la ville